let's get to this week's mailbag you can
email in info
davidpakman.com also random youtube
posts uh comments rather or reddit posts
or whatever else might end up
being featured in this segment and no
shortage of different topics to look at
many substantive which i know many of
you have been saying david i prefer the
substantive emails and comments that you
display we have quite a mix today that's
for sure um jamie wrote in jamie says
hey david
i don't usually write in but i just had
to after this i watch your content
regularly and so your videos show up in
my recommendation feed on youtube one
clip that you posted earlier today this
was last uh late last week was soaking
wet trump explodes walks out of piers
morgan interview but the phrasing of
soaking wet trump explodes brings a very
different mental image to mind this
happened in another one of your segments
when you were commenting on trump's
religiosity where you said
i i don't think trump has ever gotten on
his knees for jesus which again brings a
very different mental image to mind if
it's intentional i love it but if it's
not i thought i would let you know no
jaime we know exactly what we're doing
we know exactly what we're doing and i
absolutely love
love this email this this is
ex on this email is genius
on about three or four different levels
and uh i couldn't thank you enough for
it jamie but yes no those the the titles
are not an accident
vinco from norway wrote in and vinco
says
david first off great show i'm a loyal
listener and subscriber and american
expat living in norway
can you spa i know by the way i know the
term expat is very controversial with
some in our audience but i'm reading the
email as written can you spare a minute
to explain why some people refer to
ukraine as ukraine and others as the
ukraine
many thanks and keep up the great work i
seriously appreciate your insight on
current events so
the ukraine is a reference to the um
soviet era
where when you say the ukraine you're
sort of saying
the borderlands and so the reason that i
don't say the ukraine and i understand
it's really not correct to say the
ukraine anymore
is that the country as it exists today
as an independent country
at least for now we'll see what putin
gets away with
is that it's it's the country ukraine
if we say the ukraine it would be sort
of like saying
the outskirts or the borderlands of the
soviet union rather than an independent
country and those are the historical
origins of that i say ukraine i believe
it is correct to say ukraine
brian rhoden this is so funny
um
you you guys will understand why in a
second brian says hey david i'm brian
from toronto love the show
the other day you mentioned your agent
and you had a discussion on getting a
package to send to cnn plus but you were
thinking it's a poor idea correct me if
i'm wrong however i think it would be a
great move cnn plus is likely under
immense pressure right now you could
have a great opportunity to bring
success to the platform demonstrate the
proven content make changes from the
inside plus the contracts they're giving
out aren't too bad either you could
negotiate from a place of power as your
numbers are already proven cnn plus has
since shut down
like as as quickly as i told the story
to the audience wow cnn plus isn't doing
great they're only getting about 10 000
viewers a day we get way more than that
um and it's like all so lame that my
agent and i didn't even think to send a
proposal to them in part because i don't
want to have 20 bosses it's more about
that brian's like no it might be a good
idea and in the three days since they've
there's been an announcement that cnn
plus is just shutting down
and that's the right decision and it is
a humiliating expenditure of money for
nothing to show for it
i know i've said this before many of you
are probably getting tired if cnn took a
fraction of what they spent on cnn plus
and just said hey we're going to pick
the top 10 like youtube and podcast
shows
in the political space
and we're going to give them a fraction
of the money just to like buy ads on
youtube twitter and facebook the return
on investment would have been
dramatically better dramatically better
but sadly brian there's no more
conversation to have
because cnn plus is going bye-bye
kevin wrote in about trump 2024
kevin says i doubt that trump runs in
2024 he will blame health or claim it
won't be a fair election trump is too
big of a coward to risk losing again i
do think it would be interesting to have
a debate between two people that have
been president a normal debate the
candidates answer as to what they would
do this debate each candidate has an
actual record i i completely agree that
a debate now is it true let me think
about that has there never been a debate
between
i think that's probably true but
i'd have to actually look at the history
books on that
um
but let's assume it's true that biden
versus trump
would be the first
can campaign where both candidates have
been president
i think that would be interesting
but i also
i mean listen to be honest i worry if
trump runs and is the republican nominee
i worry that he wins and that it's a
really bad four years for the planet
and for the country and for so many
different people so my preference would
be that trump not even run it's not that
i'm scared of trump i think the risk is
the same with desantis and by the way i
think desantis would be more dangerous
because desantis is less incompetent but
my preference would be
that both options in 2024
aren't as bad as trump and trump is
starting to mention health
and that's not something he previously
did
so kevin may be on to something there
next message is from ross
ross continues to wait i guess
for the big smoking gun revelation
about
2020.
ross says biden can't even get 10 people
at a rally
everyone knows the dems and dark money
along with republican rhinos rigged the
election
it will come out in due time
my question now for the it's eventually
going to come out people
is to say how long is it going to take
we are now
four two
six eight we are 18 months now
beyond the 2020 election hard to believe
but we are
and we still have no evidence of the
fraud that they are convinced exists
so with peace and love and respect and
honesty i want to know how long is it
going to take ross let me know
chicken wrote in
about food shortages
and said this summer this is a
prediction i guess from chicken
this summer when you can't afford food
or there is no food
we'll all be laughing at you
liberals are the capital are real nazis
liberals are the ku klux klan
check your history if you can
red
losers with a capital l listen i mean
this is i'm gonna ignore the innuendo
and the ad hominems
i just have a different opinion i've
been researching the possibility of food
shortages for you know 10 days now and
did a story on it for you guys last week
i believe there will be some products
with limited availability
you know if you're obsessed with
uh
if you're obsessed with a certain
freezer waffle
you might have to choose a different
freezer waffle regionally and
sporadically
but there aren't going to be shortages
of any food group
for sure based on everything i'm reading
maybe i'm wrong you know we don't have
to call people nazis to say i have a
different opinion i just think chicken
is wrong here
harrison wrote in about book banning and
says liber this this is a genius this is
genius if it weren't so dangerous this
would be genius harrison says liberals
are for banning books just as much as
conservatives any serious liberal
doesn't want public school teachers
teaching lessons from the bible you know
what harrison that's right and it's not
about banning the bible
it's that we have separation of church
and state
public schools are funded by
property taxes and other funds from
states
meaning
that there has to be separation
between church and state you can't have
a public school
where
everybody goes of no religion and of any
religion
and say we're going to teach the bible
here now if you want to have a
comparative religion class in a public
school and maybe some high schools have
such classes using religious texts there
not to teach them as true substance but
to teach what is in them and say here's
what the old testament hebrew bible says
here's what the new testament says
here's the quran here's the spaghetti
monster thing and here's the greek stuff
you could do that in comparative
religion as a history class of sorts
but uh no it's it's against the law
to teach lessons from the bible as in
here's what we learn from the story of
noah's ark here's what we learn about
homosexuality or whether you should eat
shrimp or and
that is against the law you can't do
that so yes harrison people who follow
the law are against that groucho wrote
in and says the internet was and is way
too much for low intelligence folks most
of these people are holed away in the
same small town they were born in
completely terrified of leaving now they
have all this crazy info from snake oil
salesmen at their fingertips
and it has kicked their paranoia into
overdrive you're you're basically
describing the way reactionary politics
works
i mean groucho is using provocative
language but groucho is completely
correct you have
sheltered people
who through a combination of
a lack of economic means in some cases
and
bad parenting and you know i mean we got
to kind of tell it like it is people end
up
extraordinarily sheltered
and then they are targeted with
fear-based rhetoric
and they fall for it and then they go on
facebook and they post it and then that
creates this echo chamber and filter
bubble where they get more of the same
stuff next thing you know you're
drinking urine you know that's it's a
sad reality but groucho is spot-on
and lastly terry says
david pakman will support the war until
the last ukrainian is dead the war pig
pacman is so brave
i actually don't know where this is
coming from but the last week or so i've
been getting more and more comments and
questions that seem to assume i support
the russian invasion of ukraine i've
never said anything to suggest that i
obviously don't support the russian
invasion of ukraine
and quite frankly i would love for
people to knock it off because it's just
a waste of time i don't support the
russian invasion of ukraine so i don't
know why you would come to me and tell
me that i do
if you have a comment that you'd like to
see featured you can email info
davidpakman.com we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today become a member
really there's no better time april
beautiful month to do it
sign up at joinpackman.com
you'll get access to the bonus show
you'll get the daily show six hours
before everybody else it's a beautiful
thing